Guys...
I got bad news...
You might want to sit down.
How do I even begin to say this? 😟
All my Dr. Phil videos...
...got claimed (😱😱😱)
By Sony TV (cmon Sony, you give us spooderman and loli spooderman)
All of them
They struck out of nowhere
I wasn't even prepared
You know, Dr. Phil wore my t-shirt (totally legit btw the way)
So I thought he was a bro, okay?
I thought he would appreciate my videos and understand that it gave traction to his show
but, this of course means...
No more Dr. Phil videos (imma cri)
I know! I'm crying too and I have been crying
this is a big F, a massive F
No amount of G fuel in the world is gonna solve this problem.
I know
But instead...
*Eats dry G-fuel*
We're gonna have to watch some goddam Tik-Toks (original content)
Cuz I got nothing else planned! (pewnews maybe)
Now Dr. Phil if you're listening,
I'm not mad,
Okay?
I'm just disappointed :(
and I'm waiting!
I'm waiting,
for my apology.
and retraction, okay?
Sony ATV Publishing
Do you know what fair use is?
Huh?
Hit or miss!
But!
Never mi-
Why is the camera so close?
In the mean while,
We're gonna have to review Tik-Toks
Let's just freakin do this.
Tik-Toker: People keep saying I look scared,
like there is a person behind the camera holding a gun at me.
Pewds: No, you look like a little *****
Okay, goddamit,
Sorry, I'm upset,
I am upset!
Let's see some good Tik-Toks
Let's get some really good Tic-Toks to cheer me up.
Jackspedicey, probably: Full-time today, I know!
We haven't set off yet.
Another one: Eh
Why is 2013 JackSepticEye in my Tic-Tok feed?
Begone!
Irish man, I don't want you
There's a time and place for everything,
but not now.
This guy got 340 thousand likes just for moving his hands
Proving you need to be good looking to get likes.
*Eats G-Fuel*
When do s- I'm that good-looking guy.
Ooooh!
Well, well played.
Well I guess Eisen of the Builder. They look like Leafy, don't they?
All these TikTok kids...
they all look the same!
Wow incredible
The production quality of these have really increased massively. That must have taken forever.
We can't even do that with the green screen. Look:
*fail*
Hobo: Hey, you got the drugs?
Other hobo: Of course I got the drugs
What is Brad doing in my TikTok vid? Get out of here, man?
First Leafy, then jack now Brad?
what the Frick is going on
Not a cop
Are you of course? Not are you sure cuz if you're a cop you have to tell me does he have a septum ring?
Damn, Brian. I didn't take you for a little
No, he just has a big nose, sorry
holy sh*t It's minecraft
Don't eat it out of the can by the way, I'm just really desperate
Yeah, I only had a dog don't ever hit a dog
I don't care if it's in Minecraft that actually makes it worse. You lost my respect
TikTok community. I can't even eat G fuel now. I'm so angry The Incredible Hulk be like hulk
My spine
Okay
That was great
Guys, I don't buy you, but that was freaking cringe balling is not funny. Okay?
Whoa, holy wow, that's so
eeepic
He opened the fridge that's that's funny. That's really *oopsie* funny. I'm laughing. I'm actually laughing don't judge me
Okay, I don't need judgment. I'm having a rough day. all my Dr. Phil did all your dr. Phil videos get claimed
I don't think so. Okay. I don't understand. I don't understand how he can do this. You can't just claim videos
What is he doing? put in for your other camera
yeah, and then
and there you go brand new android
No
I'm sick and tired of everyone saying that Android has bad quality. Look at my camera quality I use an Android
and it's excellent quality
Thank you very much. Y'all just a bunch of lazy and phone (juicers? tf)
Whatever it's called I don't keep up with the kids.
Guys I'm under crisis. So my pewdiepie wall
Matter for 49 days now and I kind of want as it should by the way
If you don't have a pewdiepie wall, I got bad news for you
you might as well go unsubscribe right now (he's just kidding lmao) because that subscription
Means nothing! unless you have at least a PewDiePie altar with a candle or...
An anime girl or something god damn. accuse the one deal to not take it down though
Don't take it'll be a challenge, but I need 10,000 likes to not to get down. So good luck
Well you might think this is pretty cheap attempt to get likes
But I think it's worth it smash like on this video guys. You heard the man 10,000 likes. Can we do it?
Keep that altar up
Did you subscribe to PewDiePie what is
Raise your eyebrow if you did Wow, incredible amazing, absolutely
Who tf are these guys how do you even get your hair like that? And why?
yo- you see this? yeah. you see this
Wave check memes are not funny. Okay why they're racist. Oh, I mean I mean
I'm a Native American
We have brilliant wavy the hell are you saying I'm so confused trolling or not. I can't tell wavy shake memes are epic
Not funny. These people are just trying to bait out to like troll em' It's so not epic. Okay. I know what you're doing
Mr. Native American, okay
nobody
Yeah, I've been nice to be kind of me considerate of them. I got you guys like laughter funny ha ha
Do it with me
Why you should subscribe to t-series 10 reasons why t-series is better than Pewdie-
I didn't think you were such an enemy huh?
guess you are gonna have to die now BBC news
today actually r-
what the ff- is this I live in your country
We're supposed to be on the same side
10 reasons I can't think of a single reason
-10 reason I can't see I cannot find it. They actually delete it or it is it fake?
Jah prayer book. Oh god, it's it's about to hit zero it hit what?
Thank you jah prayer what in the world
Well, we have TikTokers on our side I guess. Jesus Christ. How is he not passed yet?
Every time it looks like it's gonna pass it just goes back up again. I don't get it
I mean hell, yeah, I'll take it but. Kev?
Yo, what's going on?
I've got Laennec my tight arms slapping hit
This will be easy. I extend my arm open my grip and brace for impact
Wait, what is he? Yeah, what is he doing? He's going for a fist bump and I'm already in Phase three
There's still time if I can close my grip and decrease my extension velocity by 40% Then I can catch him on the downswing
After that, it's just a matter of--
oh that was great, this is what people don't understand
I have an excellent handshake a lot of people say oh you don't have a good handshake. It's absolutely incredible
Hit me up with anything. I will be able to counter it because I'm always ten steps ahead
This would never happen to me always is another meme of a short people
Okay, first of all, five eleven, wait, how come I 511 180? That's what I don't even at me
511 is really tall, okay
Yeah, six feet okay got it six feet
Hey, look at six feet. This is bullshit. This is discrimination. And this is true racism in my opinion. Okay?
I don't know if I stand by those words yet. Let me just think about it a little bit. But for now, this is
I'm sick of it
My head's not broken. It's just this right. I got a healthy body but shitty brains. I'm good at rapping fast. But I can't
accept you don't even
Talk about this and why does she look like SANS? Okay. I'm just throwing that one in there as well
She looks a hell of a lot like saying that's a lot. Is it intentional being placed in front of a window?
Cuz then I can respect it. Otherwise, it's just pure cringe if she started going
*sans noises*
That would be a funny joke. Just trying to have kids out. I understand that
It's not a funny joke, but it's an ironic funny joke. Okay. Let me just clear on that
Here's my playstation is bared in xbox. Just let you know. I've only played for two years
I've been playing since halo 2 so I've played more time on Xbox that I have PlayStation here being a don't get mad
Smaller and lighter console better controller an incredibly simple home screen that has never changed Xbox. I mean, that is a good point
Actually, I can't even count them. All you Xbox players think you're so clever with your backwards compatibility in game pass
Well, we have PlayStation now, which is our game pass and backwards compatibility in one
VR it's a faster console and actually pretty decent camera more and better exclusives than just
Halo this pathetic fools these cowards that play
console games when you can have an Origin PC
Excellent computer 10 out of 10 baby really maximize the potential, you know, don't even at me with a console
What are you poor they're real poor
Everyone is like, oh you're poor if you have don't have a hair cause know you're poor if you have a gaming console
Let's get real here and let me stop my step. They're not poor just pathetic just pathetic
Oh god, what is gonna?
You know, we're getting desperate when we're doing this shit
It started off with posters
And it ends with just pure
This is me one day on steroids, this is me one week on steroids. Okay, this is
Good oh my god, everyone keep saying that I'm Orange clearly. I'm white
Can you not tell that I'm white orange is not even a race
I'm clearly at the white race not an orange. So I don't understand that comment below from orange or white cuz I'm clearly white
Alright, well, I think that about does it. Thank you guys so much for another epic video
I don't know what I'm thinking you you should be thanking me smash like subscribe buy all the merch very nice
Now everyone tweet my man. Dr. Phil, let's get they spread please I need
These copy strikes to get removed. I thought we had something special. Dr. Phil
Please do not disappoint and that's it for now because otherwise, this is all we have and it ain't good. What?
cheaper simulators becoming relevant
No, no, don't leave
No, please sponsor eagle. Please do something
Yes
This game is still relevant god damn it